Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Denise RQ
Mi han chiesto quale titolo
avrei voluto avere, come definirmi.
Io ho detto 'city changer'.
'City changer' per me
è qualcosa di fondamentale,
cioè noi siamo in un ambiente, in un mondo
che vogliamo plasmare, modificare
sulla base di quelli
che sono i nostri valori.
E questo aspetto per me è fondamentale,
alla fine di questo discorso
spero di fare anche di voi
dei potenziali 'city changer'
nei vostri piccoli mondi.
Io mi focalizzo su un aspetto
principale, la mobilità.
Che non è soltanto prendere
un mezzo e spostarsi da A a B.
È una scelta,
è la vostra scelta di vita.
Ogni giorno,
quando decidete come spostarvi
decidete chi essere
e questo è una cosa fondamentale,
una cosa che nessuno vi spiega.
Nessuno vi da gli strumenti
per capire chi volete essere nel futuro.
Io spero di poterveli dare.
Ci dicono ogni giorno
che dobbiamo essere
dei supereroi, dei superuomini:
dobbiamo andare a prendere
i nostri figli, portarli,
fargli fare attività sportiva,
dargli opportunità di scelta:
tutte queste cose
sono collegate alla mobilità.
Ogni giorno ci muoviamo
e prendiamo delle decisioni,
e nel fare queste attività
creiamo il nostro mondo,
e pensiamo di dare
delle nuove opportunità ai nostri figli.
Ma allo stesso tempo andiamo ad impattare
su quella che è la qualità della vita,
cioè quello che noi scegliamo come futuro.
La mobilità ha molto a che fare
con la qualità della vita,
e noi sappiamo benissimo
che quando facciamo questa scelta
abbiamo un impatto
non solo nella nostra vita,
ma anche con quella
che è la vita degli altri.
Perché?
Qualità della vita
sicuramente non è questo:
qualità della vita non vuol dire
rimanere impacchettati,
per ore e ore,
nel traffico, dentro una scatola
che è molto più grande di noi.
Ricordiamoci
che una scatola pesa tonnellate
per portare un mucchietto
di ossa piccoline, piccoline,
e noi ogni giorno
ci troviamo a passare ore,
anche magari
solo alla ricerca di un parcheggio.
Considerate che abbiamo fatto una ricerca
e abbiamo visto che una persona media,
prendendo la sua auto,
spende circa tre anni della sua vita
alla ricerca di un parcheggio.
Ora pensate [di avere]
tre anni della vostra vita
da utilizzare per fare qualche cosa
di molto più interessante.
Non sarebbe mica male:
si potrebbero leggere dei libri,
si potrebbero fare
delle aziende, fare altre cose.
Il nostro obiettivo è quello di cercare
di stravolgere questo assurdo paradigma.
Quindi: spazio,
utilizzare meglio
lo spazio che ci circonda,
cambiare il concetto di possesso,
e anche fare in modo che le persone
siano in grado di parlarsi di più,
perché quando siamo
nella macchina, francamente,
a parte scambiare
dei messaggini via Facebook,
non penso che ci sia molto
utile questo atteggiamento.
Questo vuol dire cambiare l'equazione,
il paradigma di noi
all'interno della società,
e vuol dire rimettere
le persone come priorità
e di fare in modo
di far capire ai politici
che questo paradigma
della mobilità assistita deve cambiare
- ma allo stesso tempo capire
che noi siamo i primi a dover cambiare.
E quindi ciò mi porta a dire
che un altro mondo
o un altro 'modo' è possibile.
Noi possiamo scegliere
la mobilità che vogliamo.
Noi possiamo deviare
quella che è una traiettoria pericolosa,
per noi e per l'ambiente,
verso qualche cosa
che possa essere un'opportunità.
Ma vuol dire saltare delle barriere.
Saltare delle barriere informative
che sono state costruite attorno a noi.
Quanti di voi ogni giorno, per muoversi,
cercano le informazioni degli orari
dei diversi autobus, dei diversi
mezzi che devono prendere,
e non ne capiscono mai niente
perché poi non sono aggiornati
e devono cercare di combinare
la mobilità in maniera manuale?
Be', questa è
la prima cosa che dobbiamo fare:
ma la seconda cosa
è quella di dover cambiare
la nostra visione della mobilità.
La mobilità non è più quello
che siamo stati abituati
a fare negli anni passati.
Ci hanno insegnato,
come primo atto di emancipazione,
di avere le chiavi della macchina.
Ora, ai 'millennials'
questo concetto di avere
la chiave della macchina
francamente non interessa.
A loro interessa capire
come muoversi, come andare al di là,
come essere efficaci
ed efficienti nelle loro scelte.
E pertanto dobbiamo
considerare questo aspetto.
Dobbiamo considerare
che la mobilità dovrà essere
come un vestito, qualcosa che si mette
e ci si veste sulla base delle esigenze.
Qualcosa di modulare e personalizzato.
Qualcosa che è un servizio,
non è più un atto di possesso.
Qualcosa che qualcuno
può utilizzare ogni giorno.
Pertanto noi abbiamo creato un progetto
che si chiama 'Super Hub'
che vuol dire grande 'hub',
grande punto di interazione,
e che vede al centro il cittadino,
nelle sue scelte quotidiane,
nelle sue scelte
di movimento all'interno della città.
E noi, attraverso questo progetto,
abbiamo cercato
di sviluppare una piattaforma
che potesse riappropriare
il cittadino delle proprie scelte.
Cioè oggi, quando decido
di uscire dalla mia porta,
invece di prendere automaticamente
il mazzo di chiavi mi chiedo:
-Ma quale possibilità ho per essere
più friendly con l'ambiente,
per fare delle scelte che sono
più concepibili
e rispettose dei miei valori?
La Commissione Europea
ci ha graziato di un lauto finanziamento,
e ci ha dato la possibilità di portare
questo progetto in Europa, e soprattutto
in tre città importanti dell'Europa:
parliamo di Helsinki,
parliamo di Barcellona
e parliamo di Milano.
Quello che noi volevamo fare
è portare la sostenibilità
ad un livello di informazione superiore,
e soprattutto di abilitarla
a tutti i livelli,
di metterla nelle vostre tasche.
Quali sono stati i paradigmi?
Prima di tutto, trasporti verdi per tutti:
dobbiamo sapere che c'è una possibilità
di essere ecosostenibili nella mobilità,
e di fare in modo che la mobilità pubblica
possa essere vista come una opportunità,
e non solo come uno schiaccianoci.
Nel senso che ogni giorno,
quando prendiamo i nostri autobus
o i nostri mezzi ci sentiamo accerchiati.
Allo stesso tempo,
ci sono degli aspetti nuovi di mobilità:
considerate tutte quelle
che sono le nuove dinamiche
- il bike-sharing, il car sharing,
il car pooling, il taxi sharing -
come delle nuove opportunità per ridurre
il nostro impatto all'interno della città.
Ma allo stesso tempo
abbiamo fatto un'altra cosa:
abbiamo messo insieme chi utilizza
la mobilità, con chi disegna la mobilità,
quindi abbiamo iniziato a fare
un processo di co-creazione.
Abbiamo iniziato a definire
quali fossero i criteri,
e lo abbiamo fatto
attraverso degli scenari
che abbiamo disegnato
insieme agli utilizzatori,
quindi abbiamo coinvolto
più di 3000 persone fra queste tre città,
che hanno iniziato a dire cosa
volevano e che cosa non volevano,
che funzionalità avere
e che cosa non avere,
che tipo di partecipazione volevano avere
nella mobilità del futuro.
E l'abbiamo fatto in modo divertente,
abbiamo utilizzato dei giochi
seriosi per coinvolgerli,
e loro hanno potuto anche capire
che la mobilità poteva
essere un'opportunità,
anche per condividere con gli amici
una scoperta della città:
quindi loro potevano dare
dei challenge ai loro amici
e mandarli in alcune parti della città
che non avevano mai visitato,
perché all'interno di quella città
ci potevano essere delle nuove idee,
delle nuove culture,
delle nuove contaminazioni.
E questo come ho detto, è stato
su tre città, ma soprattutto a Milano,
dove abbiamo chiesto agli utenti
di cercare nuove opzioni di mobilità,
dando accesso a tutte le informazioni
che prima non avevano.
Questo perché loro
potevano cercare di ridurre
le loro impronte in questo mondo.
Super Hub è diventata un'applicazione,
ma allo stesso tempo è una piattaforma
che mette insieme informazioni
provenienti dalle reti cellulari,
dai GPS, dalle applicazioni
che gli stessi utenti decidono di darci,
le informazioni che vogliono,
dai social network
e anche dai trasporti pubblici,
ma anche dai dati di parcheggio,
messi tutti insieme
e creando un indice della città
che permette anche di poter dare,
per la prima volta,
delle predizioni e delle stime
di pattern di mobilità in real time.
Questi valori ci permettono
di far fare una mobilità, diciamo,
vicina a quelle
che sono le esigenze degli utenti,
perché loro riescono
a definire le loro preferenze
quello che vogliono
e quello che vorrebbero fare,
e noi, tramite il nostro sistema
di pianificazione del viaggio,
riusciamo a dargli delle indicazioni che
sono vicine a quello che loro chiedono.
Inoltre abbiamo un sistema
che permette di fare della persuasione,
e in più questi dati riusciamo anche
a darli alla Pubblica Amministrazione,
per capire quali sono
le reali dinamiche di mobilità.
Cosa vuol dire?
Definisco quel mio obiettivo
- da dove parto, la mia casa
e dove voglio arrivare -
e ho tante opzioni di mobilità,
opzioni che mixano la mobilità,
diciamo, più ecologica,
che sono i nostri piedi,
con la mobilità sostenibile
- quindi la bicicletta, BikeMi,
la metropolitana, i taxi, le macchine -
e danno degli indicatori
di sostenibilità a livello di emissioni
ma anche informazioni importanti
come possono essere
la 'user satisfaction',
cioè quello che è vicino alle esigenze
dell'utente rispetto alle sue priorità.
Come vedete, siamo stati
anche in grado di definire
l'impatto delle politiche sulle scelte,
quindi anche per esempio inserendo
quello che per esempio è il discorso
dell'area C all'interno di Milano.
Quindi, quando io decido
di prendere la mia macchina,
di andare con la macchina,
devo essere consapevole
che ho delle sovrattasse,
e questa è una cosa molto importante.
Ma la cosa più importante
è che noi abbiamo inserito
un concetto di profilazione
dell'utente fatta dall'utente,
con l'obiettivo di migliorarsi:
cioè l'utente è il primo
a definire dei goals,
degli obiettivi motivazionali.
Io ogni giorno voglio
decidere se migliorare
ed essere più buono
per l'ambiente e per il mio futuro,
cercando di ridurre per esempio
le mie emissioni di CO2,
oppure cercando di essere più attivo,
quindi camminare di più
e far bene anche alla mia salute.
Noi siamo in grado di dare
un diario di bordo
e anche di spiegare quelle che sono
tutte le opzioni di mobilità,
collegandolo anche a un indice
di performance che poi può risultare
anche in "punti verdi".
Questi punti verdi potrebbero
essere qualcosa di interessante,
cioè potrebbero dare un'indicazione
della bontà di un cittadino
all'interno di una città.
E questo potrebbe essere anche utilizzato
non solo come esempio per gli altri,
ma anche come qualcosa
che la Pubblica Amministrazione
potrebbe dare
come riconoscimento ai cittadini,
per la loro capacità di impegno
verso un tema così importante
come sono la riduzione delle emissioni.
Allo stesso tempo,
abbiamo fatto qualcosa di più,
abbiamo creato un marketplace
della mobilità: mobilità sostenibile.
Quindi posso comprare dei biglietti
direttamente dall'applicazione
collegata alla mobilità, biglietti
del tram, validarli in applicazione
e quindi riducendo
anche il volume di carta stampata
che ogni giorno
siamo costretti a comprare.
Last but not least,
abbiamo fatto anche qualcos'altro.
Abbiamo dato degli indicatori
ai policy maker,
che sono stati in grado di vedere
come l'impatto di grandi eventi
può destrutturare la mobilità urbana,
creando per esempio
dei "colli di bottiglia"
in quello che si chiama mobilità.
Ad esempio, in sistemi di grandi nevicate,
quando abbiamo avuto
delle grandi nevicate,
oppure un grande evento
come può essere una partita allo stadio,
siamo riusciti a capire come e dove
si creavano questi colli di bottiglia,
e a cercare per esempio di far deviare
il traffico in altri posti,
in modo da cercare di avere
una mobilità meno "a macchia
di leopardo" come la vediamo qui,
e soprattutto dare
gli strumenti ai policy maker
di vedere in tempo reale
quella che poteva essere
l'evoluzione della città
sulla base di queste tecniche.
Quello che vogliamo abilitare
è la città "intelligente"
su questo livello base che abbiamo dato
e che - considerate [che] la mobilità
è il primo degli elementi
di una smart city.
Dobbiamo costruire qualcos'altro.
Il lavoro che è stato fatto
è stato riconosciuto,
la Commissione Europea
ci ha dato un premio
come migliore innovazione
nelle smart city nel 2013,
e abbiamo ottenuto un ulteriore premio
a Milano ultimamente,
per il Bus City Tank.
Ma questo è soltanto l'inizio:
quello che vogliamo fare
è creare una fondazione,
un'associazione per la mobilità aperta
dove per la prima volta si possono mettere
tutto il patrimonio di open data
e dove i cittadini possono
iniziare a riversare,
in maniera consapevole
- questo è fondamentale,
devono essere i cittadini
a decidere di dare i loro dati
all'interno di questo sistema -
per creare un sistema
di mobilità 'door to door'
a livello europeo.
Quindi domani, se volete
andare da Como a Barcellona
avete tutti gli strumenti per decidere
quale mobilità volete essere.
Quindi, sono come mi muovo.
E io spero che nel futuro
voi abbiate la possiblità
di accedere a questi strumenti
per decidere quello che volete essere.
Grazie.
(Applausi)